he is the uh senior analyst at pro
football focus
steve palazzolo how's that
pal alonso i know
can okay fritzy you want to try steve
palazzolo palozzolo mclovin
yes steve palazzolo all right
paulie palazzolo
acceptable steve palazzolo joining us uh
senior i got the steve part right there
now you worked for pro football focus
but you were also
in the minor leagues for how many years
uh eight years between uh independent
ball and a couple
affiliated teams okay the your your
favorite minor league story is what
oh man i mean i just well i'll brag a
little bit when i threw
in aaa buster posey was my catcher okay
and i threw 16 scoreless innings to him
in relief
over about a month and then they put it
you know then i threw to the back up one
time gave up five
so i like to think backup catcher just
you know it was his fault let me throw
the buster
the best player you gave up a home run
to was who
uh carlos gonzalez i think
he was pretty good cargo yeah yeah it
was not bad
and and how many uh how many stops along
the way did you have in the minor
leagues
eight years about eight stops nine stops
i was with the giants brewers mariners
all over the place bunch of independent
ball and uh made it up to triple a
for a little bit how close to uh being
real is bull durham in your opinion
is bold yeah i think there's a lot of
there's a lot of realism to it obviously
they're taking it to the next level with
some of the one-liners and stuff like
that but you know the bus
trips and the the challenges and all
that stuff pretty pretty well defined
there but you didn't have a susan
sarandon
maybe waiting after the game for you in
the minor leagues i have no comment not
me
but i'll tell you what there was there
is some
interesting minor league cities i'll say
that not me but the
interesting it's an interesting world
dan i'm sure it is
uh i think when i was growing up they
were called stage door jones
yeah so um all right well thanks for
joining us here and i saw that
pro football focus i have great respect
for pro football focus that uh you have
their quarterbacks
and you have different tiers here so
explain how you came up with the
criteria of where you were ranking these
quarterbacks
yeah so i'm just like i'm naturally i'm
not good for tv because everybody wants
this really nice hot take and you've got
quarterback one and quarterback 32 and
i'm like look that's just not how the
nfl works right so you've got
i've always looked at the tier one
quarterback and i think through the
years you said okay that's brady that's
brees
rogers payton those guys can carry a
team no matter what happens
tier two i feel like there's always you
know six or eight guys in the league at
any given time that you feel like hey
they can carry an offense
you want to have a good situation around
them they're just just outside that top
tier
and then tier three is probably that
more most extensive
group where you have these guys any
given year if the
you know if the situation's right the
play calling the play makers they can
have a great year
if that stuff's not there they're not
looking all that good i think there's a
big group of signal callers
that fit into that tier three and then
four is
either an unknown or these guys are you
know maybe their last year starting
their last opportunity
uh they're young they haven't proven it
yet so i just tried to throw guys into
those
various buckets because i think it's uh
i think there are some somewhat clear
lines
around the nfl these days okay your top
tier quarterbacks or who
just patrick mahomes and russell wilson
and i think again this was one of those
brady was always there
and brees was always there i think with
their age they're declining just a touch
i think aaron rodgers we've seen him
decline in recent years he hasn't been
that guy who no matter who you throw
around him
the results are there so i think all
those guys dropped down a little bit
patrick mahomes
pretty much stepped right in to being a
tier one quarterback since he started
and i would say russell wilson kind of
jumped up from two to one over these
last couple years he was always very
good he was always one of those top
eight guys
but he's right there with mahomes and
our throw by throw grading over the last
two seasons
why is lamar jackson tier two i think
with lamar it's just let's see it one
more time you know i think i think an
important part of
you know doing this work is saying last
year is not the only thing that happened
right you know two years ago he wasn't
all that accurate
he did improve that last year i think
it's just hey let's see it one more time
and then a year from now
he could be in tier one how big of a
drop off have we had with tom brady
i don't think it's nearly as big as the
stats would show last year he was our
12th graded quarterback last year but i
think by all statistical measures he was
25th or 26th or whatever
it might have been so i think that's
kind of the beauty of the pff system we
could say look we're going to grade
every single throw
how you know where you throw it the
accuracy the decision making
but the stats and the output are so
dependent on play makers and play
calling in the situation as i was
mentioning
i think that took a massive step back
for brady last year so i would say he's
taken slight steps back
over the last couple years but not
nearly as bad as the numbers would show
so
you would think assuming he picks up the
system with bruce aries
they're on the same page he should have
a better season with all those
playmakers around him
who else is there tier two um so we've
got uh so we mentioned lamar
uh why am i drawing a blank right now on
these guys desean watson uh
you know he's one of those guys so
watson's kind of like russell wilson in
past years wilson would always have
those
two or three games where you just
massively question
uh you know why is he having this
terrible game that's watson right now
you know like one week he's an mvp
candidate the next week he's terrible i
think he's right there
in that mix matt ryan has uh quietly
been
really really good year in year out he's
coming off a rough season but
i think matt ryan is going to be right
up there i mentioned brady and brees
they're both in there
and then aaron rodgers who i mentioned
before too you know again i don't think
he's been
a tier one quarterback but he's still
certainly more than capable if they put
better playmakers around him in green
bay he'd
i think he'd bounce back you know quite
a bit yeah but they don't have better
playmakers in green bay
no they don't i don't like their
strategy right now i think they're
trying to
essentially take the ball out of rogers
hands rather than put it in his hands
and i think that's
potentially a mistake if they focus too
much on the run game steve palazzolo
joining us on loan from pro football
focus one of their senior analysts
if i said you could sign one of these
quarterbacks and for the same price the
next five years i gave you garoppolo
goff prescott wentz oh man
i think it's between wence and prescott
and i think
i think it's more just because of their
high end capabilities that they are
all in that tier three they've all had
great seasons one of my favorite
ways of breaking down that 2016 class
you've got wence you have goth
uh and you have dak uh they've all been
our top graded quarterback
in one you know in in a season dak now
has two of them in the four years
they've been in the league so
i'd probably lean either wence or dak i
i'll go with dak right now because i've
just seen
what he can do with that really nice
supporting cast but it's it's really
really close i'd say between dak and
wenz
do you think dax a great quarterback no
i don't think he's great
so here's what i think the nfl i think
over the last decade if you went back
and
everybody put together a top eight
quarterback list you'd almost
certainly land around the same names i
think we're at this transitional point
uh where ben roethlisberger has dropped
off and phillip rivers brady brees all
those guys right
we don't know what that next tier is so
i think dak could be
in that next group i just don't know
that they're there yet i think we're
just in this world of
middle class quarterbacks and i think
dak is in that boat i think wentz is in
that boat
where again if you give dak amari cooper
and michael gallup and kellen moore call
him plays
you're going to get great production
like he did last year you're going to
get carson wentz's 2017
season where he was an mvp candidate
everybody thought year two here he goes
he's going to be the next big thing but
it was the situation it was everything
around him that was great i think that's
the state of the nfl there's a bunch of
middle-class quarterbacks dak being one
of them where when the situation's great
they can have top 10 production would
you rather have josh allen or kyler
murray
oh i'm going kyler on this uh we we butt
heads with bill
bill's fans quite a bit i think josh
allen's just you know they won a lot of
games last year he's just so
inconsistent uh highest percentage of
negatively graded throws in our system
last year he just misses too many he did
take
steps forward the rushing ability is
nice but i think kyler's just he's more
accurate better decision maker
has that same dynamic rushing ability i
would take kyler over allen going
forward who's the lowest
rated starting quarterback
i'm not i told you dan i just put tears
out here i'm not trying to
to trash anybody but um you know
darnold's down there trubisky's down
there
you know trubisky was one of those guys
i think our system did a really good job
of saying hey 2018 was a mirage you know
they won a lot of games
the stats were really good he did not
grade well at all um and he regressed
last year i think it kind of backed up
our numbers so i think when you look at
what trubisky's done i don't know if
he's considered a starter right now with
foals in there but
yeah he's been among the worst over the
last couple years if cam newton was
healthy where would he be on this list
see i think he's he's right in that tier
three
i think he's right in the middle and i
think when you go back and look at cam's
career
the headlines are interesting right the
patriots signed former mvp cam newton i
think
he was an mvp but one out of his eight
seasons he's been an elite quarterback
you know i think when you really look at
his career he's been good not great
well his rookie year he was really good
yeah he was really he's put
he he broke rookie records which were
you know a lot of passing yards and
you know like first game passing yards
things that don't really i don't think
matter going forward so i think he's
been really good
throughout his career 2015 was
exceptional but he's a good not great
quarterback people are talking hall of
fame for cam i just don't see it
but i think with new england there's a
skill set to tap into right do they want
to
run him a little bit he's on a one-year
deal so i think he's a tier three
quarterback which means
the patriots use him well if some of
those play makers emerge yeah he could
put up some some pretty good production
let me go back to the stats that i uh
was reading to the audience about
russell wilson why is it seattle hasn't
gone all in
to surround russell wilson with a potent
offense
like the rams did with jared goff and
like the niners did with jimmy garoppolo
i think it's a philosophy that they have
to run the ball to win i really think it
starts with pete carroll saying look we
have to run the ball and i think there's
there's anecdotal evidence right like
when
when we had a marshawn lynch and when we
had that defense we won a super bowl and
we were one play away from winning two
and i think they think that's how they
have to win and then there was one year
i think 2015 they kind of unleashed
russell wilson hey go chuck it we got no
passing game and they didn't
they didn't win um and then there was
another year they unleashed them and
they didn't make the play 2017 they
didn't make the playoffs
and then in 18 they said all right we're
getting back to the running game we're
taking the ball out of wilson's hands
and they made the playoffs by like one
game and i think their thinking is just
wrong
um in that i think it's um so they think
they need to run the ball
to win when the reality is instead of
having russell wilson drop back 25 times
like if he drops back 35 times he'll be
okay he can carry this team and they
need to
they need to put the ball in his hands
and to your point yeah add those
playmakers around him
uh i don't need you to necessarily
assess jamal adams but
the importance of the safety position in
today's
nfl is what compared to edge rusher
uh cornerback and anybody else you want
to throw in there on defense
so the tricky part here i'd say so it's
cornerback first and a lot of the
research we've done is actually if you
if you want to build a team you want to
do it from back to front that's kind of
the opposite of
the way i think the nfl has thought
about it through the years the ravens
did that last year
um and obviously seattle's doing it
right now they have our lowest graded
or our lowest ranked defensive line
going into the year in their secondary's
top five now with jamal adams so
i'd say quarterback's most important if
you know you're gonna get a good safety
it is actually probably more valuable
than
the edge rusher that makes 15 million a
year so i don't mind this deal overall
for seattle but
if you're going to invest in a safety a
do-it-all safety like jamal adams who
can play
every single position affect your run
defense your pass coverage and actually
rush the passer a little bit
uh i think there's a ton of value there
the question of compensation though is a
separate one
if i said you could have jamal adams or
d'andre hopkins if you're seattle
i'm always taking the receiver i mean
again why didn't they make a run on
deandre hopkins or stefan diggs if
you're going to make a run on jamal
adams
i i honestly think because they want to
run the ball
my theory for team building my theory
for team building is you try to get
four deep as far as your receivers in
tight ends
right you want to have four guys where
defensive coordinators are staying up at
night to stop you and i think seattle's
looking at well we got they got their
two they got dk metcalf they have tyler
lockett
um they still feel pete carroll's a
defensive coach they feel like they need
to win with defense that's why they did
it i think i disagree i would
you throw hopkins into the mix you throw
stefan diggs into the mix and you know
make life difficult for defensive
coordinators to me that's how you win
in today's nfl great stuff steve we
appreciate your time and now that we
figured out how to pronounce your name
then we'll have you back on the show
perfect anytime appreciate it he was the
pallbearer and that that's the nickname
were you known as the pallbearer in uh
minor leagues
no no i was not good enough to have any
nickname
i think i was the leaning tower of some
sort of tower of something
i don't know well you're six six nine
right six ten i listed six ten
so six foot seven the leaning tower of
something
a picture i forget what it was i get to
look it up it's on the internet
somewhere
thank you steve thank you uh senior
analyst pro football focus